my name is rajesh tadani
i did my doctoral work at the forestry
school at yale on the oak pine ecosystem
in the himalaya in the central himalaya
after which i went back to india and
worked in a grassroots ngo called the
central himalayan rural action group or
chiragon short
which worked in about 150 villages
across the central himalaya
i am currently associated with an
organization called cedar or the center
for ecology development and research and
our objective is to do applied
research
which is of relevance either for policy
makers or for grassroots ngos in the
himalayas
uh i've always been fascinated with the
himalaya i spent some time there as a
kid my father used to work in the
himalaya
and
it is the largest physical
feature in in india and is responsible
for the climate of north india
as well as
essential for the livelihoods of about a
billion people that live in the
indo-gangetic plains
due to the ecosystem services provided
by it
it's also a nice place to walk and check
in and a very beautiful place
one of the easier and nicer places to do
field work
the himalaya has for millennia been
well populated
at present
there is over extraction of biomass
products which would mean fuel wood
fodder fertilizer which are products
that are used to support the
agroecosystem the nutrient input is not
through chemical fertilizers but it is
largely through leaf litter which is
swept up from the forest uh people use
firewood for energy and the cattle which
is an integral part of the agro
ecosystem
are fed leaves which are usually lopped
or
the branches of trees that are pruned
from the forest
this has resulted in some level of
over-extraction
which has had deleterious impacts on the
himalayan forest in the northeastern
part of the himalaya a certain amount of
timber extraction still continues which
is a problem but
in the central himalaya it is largely
what we call a chronic disturbance a low
intensity
continuous disturbance
which is a threat to the forest
in addition
global warming now is proving to be a
bit of a problem because it appears to
have changed the climatic patterns a bit
which means that agricultural patterns
have had to change
crops that used to grow at a particular
elevational range don't do as well any
longer
we seem to be getting more intense
storms
more intense rainfall events uh which
have had
impacts um there is a change in the
flora and fauna and insects which which
never used to occur in fungal diseases
which never used to occur uh seem to be
occurring in some parts
india has for a long time had a huge
shortage of power
the
easiest supposedly greenest way to
generate more power is through
hydropower and there has been the
building of a large number of hydropower
projects across the himalaya many more
are still planned
however the himalaya are in a fairly
sesmically active zone it's it's called
a zone five which is the highest level
of sesame city um also the mountains are
relatively young they're they're well
under 60 million years old which in
geological terms is uh very very recent
they're still growing taller so it's
it's very youthful mountains and as a
result are extremely crumbly uh
situating large dams or more commonly
now what are called run of the river
projects which are basically large
pipelines which are bored through
mountains and and then give an adequate
head to generate hydropower
is extremely risky in such environments
if seismic activity occurs which it will
eventually
it could lead to problems in these
hydropower projects
hydropower is also resulting in changes
in the diversity
it is resulting in in wildlife corridors
being impacted there is a lot of
relocation of human beings which needs
to happen because as mountain systems go
the himalaya are fairly well populated
the himalaya has often been studied for
the north-south transects the very very
sudden changes in elevation from about
sea level to uh 8 000 meters or more in
a very very short distance however
what's equally interesting or more
interesting and what we are looking at
through the el himalaya initiative is
the east-west arc of the east west
transect
from afghanistan and pakistan in the
west to burma in the east
and along this gradient you have a large
variety of
environmental social and cultural
gradients you go from
dry desert-like conditions in the west
to the wettest spot on earth in
gerapunji in the eastern himalaya
you go from
a
very tropical forest with a very very
tropical trait even at mid elevational
zones to forests which have a much more
uh temperate uh trait you find the
entire spectrum of religions
most of the major religions of the
planet are well represented in the
himalayas it's it's unusual to see such
a small area with
all these various religions christianity
buddhism islam hinduism coexisting and
coexisting fairly well in many places
you have
very high endemism which is
species that are sort of unique to the
area among the western side of the
himalaya whereas on the east you have
extremely high biodiversity and it's
it's considered one of the biodiversity
hot spots of the earth
the himalaya is also
the
sort of land from where many major
rivers flow and 10 major river basins
get a lot of their water from the
himalayan region and the ecosystem
services that flow from the himalaya
impact about a fifth of humanity over a
billion people in the indo-gangetic
plains
in the plains of punjab and further
north in tibet and china
biodiversity species animals plants
don't recognize political borders and
they move whether the borders are there
or not what's interesting is that people
also don't recognize political borders
to the extent that we might think they
do
the indigenous groups there will often
cross borders which are thought to be
extremely hostile and disputed
without really thinking too much about
it
yes certainly
with
the
several of the countries
in the himalayan zone getting into
conflict borders have become a lot less
porous than they used to be
but the movement across borders still
occurs
both for the flora and fauna but also
for human beings and a certain amount of
trade that still goes on
in the u.s when we talk about forest
disturbance the focus is usually more on
what we call acute disturbance
clear cutting of forests or even
thinning of stands which results in the
removal of a fair number of trees
in the western himalaya in particular
the disturbance is different we call it
chronic disturbance
it is something that happens repeatedly
but is of a much lower intensity the
agro ecosystem which
which which forms the main
livelihood pattern of the local people
there
is very dependent on
these biomass products which would be a
wood which is not
obtained through the cutting of entire
trees but rather the lopping of branches
leaf litter which is obtained by
sweeping the forest floor clean off
leaves that fall once a year that's a
very interesting pattern of the
himalayan trees the western himalayan
trees most of them lose their leaves
after 12 months of of getting them and
almost all of them lose their leaves in
the spring in march and april and after
that
women from villages correct collect
these headloads of leaves and take them
out of the forest
fodder is also obtained largely from the
forest and interestingly enough in this
ecosystem
people lock the trees remove leaves from
high branches
and and take them to feed to their
cattle
uh whereas if you move from the western
part of the himalaya uh
cattle and buffalos
are really the main
livestock that are present there and
they are integral to the agricultural
systems in the past they were the only
source of uh draft power they were used
to plow the fields
you still cannot have much mechanization
on those slopes so you still need
ox when you want to plow your fields
the
interestingly the cattle dung that comes
from these
cows was used to form the main
fertilizer for the fields it was
composted along with the leaf litter and
that was the main nutrient input
but as we go east
you moved into a different kind of
agricultural practice you had shifting
agriculture or slash and burn
agriculture as it's known where the
trees would all be cut down either
stubble would be burnt
the area would be cultivated for two or
three years and then the ecosystem would
be left to recover for a period of five
to fifteen or twenty years
in those areas the importance of cattle
is much less
but meat becomes extremely important and
piggery is is the main
livestock that you find in the eastern
himalayan
biogas is an extremely interesting
technology which hasn't got the
importance that it should be getting in
the western himalaya
we
carry out afforestation programs there
with the hope that the forest will come
back
but unless the local people there have
an option have alternatives to firewood
you cannot have forests coming back
liquid petroleum gas which is used along
the road head is not very practical to
get into the interior parts of the
himalaya and biogas forms an extremely
important and interesting alternative
to fuel wood
what happens with biogas is that the
dung or cow dung is mixed with water
made into a slurry
put into a large chamber which is
airtight which is built for this purpose
and left to ferment
methane gas is released
which forms an extremely clean fuel
which can be used for cooking
the residue that is left the slurry
which which is uh
reduced in carbon content which comes
out as methane gas
still has all the nutrients in it so it
makes an extremely effective fertilizer
all the pathogens and and nematodes and
other things uh in the slurry are killed
through the biogas process so it's a
it's a very good fertilizer more
nutritious and and with much less in
terms of uh disease
the other good thing with biogas is that
it's a clean fuel
at present there's a lot of attention
that's been focused to what we call
black carbon small residues particles of
carbon which get into the upper
atmosphere largely as a result of
biomass burning
burning
dirty fuel woods which have moisture in
them in particular and this black carbon
gets into the upper atmospheric layers
it forms a haze it gets deposited on the
glaciers in the himalaya which increases
their the ability of the glaciers to
absorb sunlight and
increases the rate of melt of glacier so
it's a really serious problem when you
use biogas you don't get black carbon to
that extent so again it's it's better
for the environment it's better
also of course for the local villagers
who use it because the respiratory and
eye ailments which tend to be very very
high amongst women who cook on wood
fuels
is much much lower when they're using
bio gas
however biogas has not found
the kind of acceptability
or has not spread as well as we would
have hoped the major issue we see with
biogas is the high up front cost um a
one to two cubic meter biogas plant
which is what would be required for a
for a typical family which would be five
or six people would cost about 10 to 15
000 rupees or about 300
or so
to construct
this represents a fairly large amount of
money for
rural people and it is one reason why it
doesn't get built as often as it should
however the savings from biogas in terms
of
carbon sequestration that occurs when
you're not burning so much wood in terms
of impacts on health in terms of impact
on on overall global warming and black
carbon would be worth a lot more than
three hundred dollars so this would be
what i would call a good subsidy even if
we have to
pay people
most of the amount they need to build a
biogas plant it would be well worth it
a few other problems with biogas also
include it requires a little bit of
water so where acute water shortages
occur it doesn't work that well and you
need some trained technicians so while
the level of engineering expertise is
very very basic to keep a biogas plant
functional if people don't have that you
often have the pipelines getting clogged
with a little bit of water maybe in and
just because people don't know how to
drain it
it ceases to function
the himalayan ecosystem is also
extremely interesting to study for
things like chronic disturbance or for
for other kinds of studies
because the uh flora the the large trees
there
are relatively
lacking in diversity which makes it easy
to model this ecosystem for example
we have mainly two species at the mid
elevational range which exists over much
of the himalaya
these are the oaks and the pines and you
have a few species of oak and largely
one species of pine
human disturbance tends to
increase the distribution of pine over
oak because oak has a fuel wood which
has extremely high calorific value so
it's preferred for burning the leaves of
oak
are relatively nutritious it's not a
great fodder but it's the most available
fodder so the tree tends to be lopped
by humans and finally the leaf litter is
extremely nutritious again and and forms
a much better compost than most other
kinds of trees
in most trees when the leaf is about to
fall there's a high re-translocation of
nutrients back into the tree and the
leaf that fall actually has fairly low
levels of nitrogen and phosphorus and
other nutrients
in
quercus leucotrichophora and other
himalayan oaks there is a fairly high
level of nutrients that is left in the
leaves in other words the reed
translocation is low what this does is
that the leaves that fall onto the
forest floor are rich in nutrients they
rot more easily
and the nutrients goes back into the
forest soils and then can be reabsorbed
by the trees so you have a external mode
of
nutrient movement rather than than the
tree just
bringing the leaves back but as a result
of its utility to the local people
banjok or the other oaks in the himalaya
tend to be locked much more
they are more susceptible to fire in
that
seedlings tend to be damaged more than
the seedlings of pine would be damaged
they tend to be grazed more so when
cattle are left in the forest oak
seedlings tend to be impacted more and
all of these together result in the
distribution of pine visory oak
increasing
which actually is converse to what
normally happens you normally have oak
taking over from pine but because of
human disturbance pine often takes over
from oak in the himalaya
so when we think of the himalaya we
think of these high snow-capped
mountains and rightly so
pretty much all the highest peaks in the
world are in the himalaya
but when we actually
look at a section of the himalaya it's
not all snow-capped peaks
the himalaya rises fairly suddenly to
about 2000 meters
but after that it stays at about that
elevation for some 150 kilometers or so
and varies from 1500 to maybe two and a
half thousand meters after which it
suddenly rises up to six or seven
thousand meters
now what this does is is something
interesting in that the there is a broad
expanse of land about 150 kilometers in
depth in the southern himalaya which is
extremely suitable for
human settlements as well as forests
these forests have extremely high
productivity this is the zone of oak and
pine
mixed with some amount of older and
poplar and maples
actually not very different from the
kind of ecosystem in terms of species
that you would expect in in the
northeast us but very very different
species endemic species that have
extremely different characteristics
the oaks for example are evergreen uh
they're not deciduous uh they don't form
very good rings the pines have a lower
leaf lifespan than in the pines you
would see in the u.s
the needles uh fall after about 12
months or so giving the pine
almost deciduous kind of characteristic
and and in the spring you'll see the
pine trees with relatively
few needles as the old needles fall and
the new ones have not yet fully expanded
so you have this very broad expanse of
the himalaya which has high productivity
high settlements
a fairly dense population and this is
the zone that that makes for
a lot of interesting study whether you
are a sociologist an anthropologist an
ecologist
or just
looking at an integration of all of
these things
most of the trees in the himalayan
ecosystem
lose their leaves in the spring
and these leaves actually turn out to be
an extremely valuable resource for human
beings
the oak leaves for example are used to
make a compost fertilizer after mixing
them with cow dung and this is the main
nutrient input for himalayan agriculture
in the western himalaya or central
himalaya
the pine leaves are also fairly useful
they're used for packing of the
horticultural fruit
so packing of apples they're also being
used for briquetting now to produce
energy
but all of this has a fairly
significant impact on the ecosystem
which is not extremely well studied and
not very well thought out
as well government policies do not
condone in any way the removal of leaf
litter and in fact encourage the removal
of pine litter because it is thought to
cause the ground fires
at cedar we've started looking at the
impacts of leaflet removal and and
they're fairly significant
of course soil compaction occurs so you
have a more dense
more compacted soil where germination of
species is is impacted
the
soil biota gets extremely impacted from
mycorrhizae
mycorrhizae are these associations
between beneficial associations between
fungi and plant roots which help
increase the volume of soil that can be
accessed by the plant roots and our
studies found that 95 percent or more
decrease in mycorrhizae in areas where
leaf litter removal was very common
the fine roots in the upper layers
decrease
the soil carbon decreases
the soil is also a huge repository of
carbon and in the surficial layers in a
good oak forest you can have more than
three percent carbon but once the forest
gets a bit degraded leaf litter is
removed for many many years
the soil carbon levels fall to under one
percent
um now this has huge impacts on on what
kind of species will generate there
regenerate them it also has a lot of uh
impact on the diversity of uh the ground
layer the herbaceous layer that exists
there as well as
one thing which again hasn't been
studied very well at all is the soil
biota the nematodes the earthworms the
various kinds of
small critters that live in the soil
layers and these of course are extremely
impacted
the himalaya by definition almost
have problems to start with
it's it's like an adolescent kid when
when
you know you're 15 years old you tend to
have more than your fair share of
problems and i'd say it's similar with
the himalaya they're a young and growing
mountain range
which is uh very fragile where many of
the rocks uh tend to be very crumbly uh
where seismic activity is already very
high um so it's it's not a very stable
mountain range um such as the mountain
ranges such as the alps for example
which tend to be an old and stable
mountain range
the high population that has been living
there has resulted in the fragmentation
of the natural areas and as global
warming occurs and global warming
interestingly enough seems to be
occurring faster or at a at a more
accentuated rate in the himalaya the
glaciers seem to be melting a little
faster
the
climate change across the slope seems to
be higher
it is impacting the way the natural
flora and fauna can move especially now
that human beings have sort of taken
over patches of the landscape and the
corridors for migration of that flora
and fauna have been greatly cut down
so the himalaya faces threats on several
fronts
another major one is the development
activity
we all want electricity and so
hydropower needs to be built
but is hydropower are large dams or even
run of the river dams appropriate for
the himalaya
there's a lot of road building activity
going on without proper alignment once
you disturb a fragile rock
it's often very very hard to stabilize
it and roads that are built incorrectly
will result in land slips and landslides
that go on for years to come so there
are problems on on many different levels
in the himalaya
the himalaya makes an extremely
interesting research area
and in some ways it's easy to study the
tree diversity for example in the
western himalayas relatively low
but what makes it so interesting and
complex
is the interplay of
nature geology ecology forestry and
human beings
unlike other forested ecosystems in the
world you don't have large swaths of
forest and then
you know human populations on the
periphery of that
human beings integrate very very well
with the natural areas they're dependent
on the natural areas of these forests
and pretty much all the forests are
impacted by human beings in one way or
the other studying this interplay of
humans and nature and wildlife
is extremely interesting
the himalayas also been called the third
pole
in addition to the north and south pole
why do we call the himalaya pole well
that's because they've also been called
the water towers of asia that's because
there's an amazing amount of snow and
ice and glaciers that exist in the
himalaya this is very important
implications for the world if global
warming
makes those glaciers melt faster than
glaciers elsewhere
it is going to have implications not
just for global climate not just for
changes in albedo and reflectivity but
for the 1 billion people or more that
live in the indo-gangetic and other
major basins of the himalaya
but the
point is here that the study of these
glaciers or other aspects of the
himalayan ecosystem is much lower than
what we would have liked
a recent ipcc report called the himalaya
a white spot because of the paucity of
research that exists on many areas so
this is an ecosystem that really
requires a lot more attention and a lot
more research